while the Trump administration's tariffs
on steel aluminum and Chinese made Goods
have earned most of the headlines
another more obscure set of Trump backed
import duties are hitting Americans
squarely in the booze cabinet since
October the US has charged a new 25
percent tariff on single malt scotch
whiskey part of a broader set of levies
targeting hundreds of European cultural
items including Italian pasta German ham
and English wool the 25% tariff is
expected to cause Scotch exports to the
United States to drop by 20 percent over
a year practically the tariff means that
what used to be a $40 bottle of scotch
is now going to set you back more than
50 bucks
smaller distilleries will be
particularly hard hit because the
tariffs specifically targets single malt
scotch whiskey that means that blended
varieties like those sold by most major
brands are exempt so those prices will
likely remain the same some small batch
producers like the Fife based Kings barn
distillery are reportedly delaying their
plans to tap into the lucrative and
growing US market because of the new
tariffs Trump has repeatedly reached for
tariffs which are really nothing more
than taxes paid by American importers
and consumers as part of a misguided
attempt to force other countries to
negotiate trade deals with the US but
the Scotch tariffs are somewhat separate
from the current administration's myriad
trade wars whiskey has become collateral
damage in a long-running spat between
the US and the European Union over
subsidies - of all things airplane
manufacturers the World Trade
Organization gave the us permission to
impose those tariffs on EU exports last
year including on whiskey after the u.s.
claimed that Airbus was being unfairly
subsidized by the French government
the main rival to Airbus is of course
Washington state based Boeing a heavy
hitter in American politics that's also
the recipient of generous corporate
welfare the whole episode demonstrates
the foolishness of tariffs American
consumers of whiskey wine and wool are
not subsidizing Airbus but people and
businesses on both sides of the Atlantic
are being punished
simply for trying to amicably trade what
they have for what they want whiskey
distillers have always had to account
for the Angels share that small amounts
of whiskey that are lost to evaporation
during the aging process but now thanks
to the Trump administration
they have to plan for the tariff man's
cut too